economía azul y turismo sostenible han
sido dos de los temas centrales de este
segundo día de la conferencia award
Ocean Y es que el océano no solamente
nos provee vida sino también un recurso
económico para hablar de eso nos
acompaña Mario Gómez el fundador y
director de la organización mexicana
Beta diversidad Mario gracias por estar
con nosotros y bueno Qué significa
turismo sostenible sobre todo en una
región como donde usted la está
proponiendo Baja California Sur bien el
turismo como lo comentaba yo hace unos
minutos una conferencia es una
oportunidad o una amenaza Yo creo que el
turismo creciente que tenemos ahí es
básicamente el turismo que está
representado por la biodiversidad que
existe es un área muy rica es un
ecosistema Marino extraordinariamente
exquisito que está beneficiado por los
las la corriente que viene del Ártico
que es la corriente de California y la
corriente ecuatorial que cuando se
cruzan una una de ellas impulsa a la
otra corriente la parte interior del
Golfo de California que también
conocemos turísticamente Como mar de
Cortés y cómo es la situación de la
sobrepesca en esta confluencia de las
dos corrientes en esa región se pescan
el 70% de Las capturas que hace México
se Ejecutan en esa región sobre pesca es
básicamente la industria pesquera lo que
en una ciudad turística como los cabos
capturan una embarcación pesquera en una
noche es lo que capturan todas las
comunidades asentadas desde Los Cabos
hasta la paz a 400 kilómetros de
distancia pero en todo el año Entonces
eso te dice en automático las
diferencias entre saber pescar bien como
Los Pescadores ribereños que pescan de
uno por uno o una industria que con un
barco se puede llevar la pesca de todas
las comunidades en una noche lo que
pescan ellos en un año sobre pesca como
una de las grandes amenazas de los
océanos y turismo como también una
amenaza o también una solución